MALE SPEAKER: Greetings.
Today we want to
welcome Brianna Wu, who
is the co-founder and head of
development at Giant Spacekat,
the game studio nearby.
She is also on a couple
of podcasts at Relay FM--
Isometric, which is about
the gaming industry,
and Rocket, which I think is
about assorted geekery topics.
So welcome, Brianna.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIANNA WU: Thank you so
much for coming today.
All right.
I want to thank Google
for having me today.
And you know,
[? Kose, ?] I know you
were responsible
for getting me here,
so I definitely appreciate that.
My name is Briana Wu.
I'm head of development
at Giant Spacekat.
I'm kind of an expert
in the Unreal Engine.
You know, when I
got into this field,
like most software
engineers, I did this
because I love engineering,
I love programming,
I love all this geeky stuff.
When I was a child, I
remember, my parents were
so hesitant to
get me a computer,
because they knew that
the moment they did,
I would just stay
in my room non-stop
and never leave the house.
So when I find myself,
especially in this last year,
kind of being an unintentional
figure for women in tech,
I just want to
let you know, this
isn't why I got into this
field in the first place.
That leads to our first slide.
Why do we have to
talk about this?
What I've discovered
along the way
is that we really don't have a
choice-- women in this field--
to talk about gender issues.
These things we're going
to be talking about today,
they really make or break the
careers of women in this field.
Sometime I sit there and
listen to my male colleagues
in the field, and I
watch what they tweet
and what they talk about.
It really amazes
me just how little
thought they have to apply to
some of these social things
that a lot of women engineers
have to talk about and think
about every single day-- little
things like being talked over
in meetings, not being
recommended for promotions.
Google itself has done a
lot of really wonderful work
on unconscious bias.
What I want you to
know is, I would rather
be up here talking about
anything else today--
Unreal Engine, implementing
Unreal on Android, OpenGL,
just about anything.
But the only way it's
going to get better for me
and the other women
that work in this field
is by talking openly about that.
So this can be a presentation
today-- I'm not Oprah Winfrey,
I'm a software
engineer, and I'm just
going to lay it out
on the table for you
in the same way I
would a software bug.
When I made this talk a few
years ago, I was on my way
down to WWDC, and I kind of
threw it together on a whim.
What really struck
me at the time
is these issues of gender in
tech had really come to a head.
This was early in 2014.
My friend Julie Ann
Horvath received
a lot of gender based
harassment at GitHub.
I'm sure you read about that.
There was a founder
that was accused
in some really horrific ways of
beating up his girlfriend 152
times on tape.
You have things like
Code Babes coming out.
Google, which I think
speaks to your credit,
now have released your numbers
of diversity in the workforce.
I think it's really worth noting
that when that story came out
in 2014, I and a lot of people
were like, this isn't so good.
But with you being
open with that number,
you started to see a
trend of other companies
like Apple bringing that number
out, and it's not any better.
So I think that
speaks to your credit.
And for me, every single
time I give this talk,
it's more and more
frustrating to me
because there are
these incidents that
break out about
what women in tech
are facing that make the news.
And every single
time, it just gets
longer and longer and longer.
It got to the point
where I couldn't even
update these slides.
It would just keep going
through it for 10 minutes.
So we're just going to go
through it super quick here.
For me, one of the most
bizarre experiences of my life
is I prepared this talk before
Gamergate happened to me.
Now, I don't know if
you're aware of what's
happened to me in this year.
I'm up to 165 death threats
in the last 11 months
in this field.
I have to talk to the
FBI and prosecutors
this week about
updates in my case
and trying to get some of
these things prosecuted.
What I've kind of
unintentionally found
is by speaking out
on these issues,
it's literally put
my life in danger.
I hope that kind of
communicates to you
how strongly I feel
about being up here
talking about this today.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to go through nine
things very quickly,
and there's going to
kind of be a negative,
and there's going
to be a positive.
What we're going
to be talking about
is some unconscious things that
men in this field tend to do.
And before we get
into this, I just
really want to make this clear.
Google has done some amazing
work on unconscious bias,
and it's really important
to note, these problems,
if you do them, do not
make you a bad person.
I myself have some of the
same unconscious bias myself.
I remember, I was at
Apple two years ago,
and I was sitting
there, and a man
was trying to sell
me a computer,
and a woman was trying
to sell me a computer.
And I found myself
unconsciously realizing,
I was talking more to the
man about my computer needs,
and I'm a woman in tech figure.
We all have problems with these
kind of unconscious biases.
So I just want you to
know, this is not personal.
This is just talking about a
problem in an objective way.
So the first thing I
would like to talk about
is, you need to
stop treating sexism
like it's just another
controversy to discuss.
There is an inevitable
pattern that happens.
Two days ago, I wrote a piece
for Polygon praising Kojima's
team for making women a playable
character in "Metal Gear Solid
5."
The game has gotten quite a
bit of sexist controversy.
This is a piece I didn't
think would be controversial,
because I was actually praising
an aspect of the game-- again,
they had gotten a lot
of feminist criticism.
And what I found to happen
was, although my response was
a lot more positive
than usual, I
was inundated with
men talking to me,
emailing me, writing me,
dynamiting into of my house,
doing whatever, wanting
to discuss it with me.
And this is a
really common theme
when we're talking about
sexism in the workplace.
This is not like talking about
the ending of "Lost" or a TV
show.
This is not like
trying to talk about,
is a blue dress or a gold dress?
These are deeply, deeply
personal issues for all of us.
And what ends up
happening is sometimes,
when you try to talk about
your lived experiences
in this field, you'll have male
engineers who come up to you,
and they start talking
about it like it's
a problem of
implementing a framework.
Like they are
completely objective
and just trying to
think through it.
What I think they
don't realize in
that moment is it's a
real unconscious problem,
because what you are
doing is kind of saying,
prove to me that you're right.
And there's an
unconscious message there
that my lived experiences
are not-- your opinions
on this trump my own
lived experience.
This is not a very
helpful way to do it.
What you're unconsciously
doing is when I say, look,
I have had x problem of
sexism with x, y, and z,
and you're like,
yeah, prove it to me,
yeah, well, have you
thought about this,
oh, well, it's just
x, y, or z, you
are dismissing my life
and the difficult things
that I've gone through.
What we need you to do is to
start showing basic sensitivity
instead.
I want to give you an example.
I had a really good,
lifelong friend of mine
that went through a
divorce a few years ago.
I knew his wife,
I knew his child,
and when my friend was
sitting there talking
to me about his divorce, I
didn't sit there and say, hey,
but did you really
try to make her happy?
Were you really present there?
I know you feel like she's
being unreasonable on this,
but I'm sure it was just blah.
That would be unbelievably
obnoxious, right?
But that is what happens
every single time
that women start talking
about our experiences in tech.
And again, this is
not intentional.
But what men in this
field end up doing
is telling us that our own
interpretation of our own lives
is incorrect.
You need to understand, when
we talk about this stuff,
it is very difficult for us.
It is emotionally risky.
We're trusting you.
That leads us into this.
This is something that
happened back in 2014.
I'm a woman in my 30s, OK?
If I'm telling you
I get catcalled down
the street, trust
me, that's something
that's really happening.
I'm an engineer.
I'm talking about being out
in San Francisco at WWDC
and getting harassed
constantly on the street.
So I tweet about
this, and I end up
getting literally
hundreds of responses
to this telling me that my
interpretation of my own life
is wrong.
This happens all the
time in technology.
Again, this is very hurtful.
What we need you to do instead
is just stop doing that.
Again, this is every
single day of our lives.
There are some things that you
have to live to experience,
and let me give you an example.
We've talked a lot this
year about police violence
towards people of color,
particularly black people.
I have the privilege of
being white in our society.
When I get pulled
over by the cops,
I don't have to stress
that the cops are
going to be violent to me.
A lot of people in this room
today have that same privilege.
I can't speak to any number
of experiences in life,
and that is true for all of us.
So when someone is black
and they are telling you
about their experiences
with law enforcement,
you need to just listen
to it, and understand
that that lived experience
trumps your own hypotheses
about the situation.
If someone gay is telling
you about coming out
to their parents, or
the discrimination they
faced as a child, you
need to listen to them.
If someone is transgender
and they are telling you
about the difficulties
in transitioning,
you need to listen to them.
Even if the opinion were
hypothetically incorrect,
the emotion that that person
is feeling is absolutely true.
I want to tell a very
quick story about this
related to this point.
A few years ago, they were doing
a study on Alzheimer's patients
who have this phenomena of, when
you put them in assisted living
care facilities, they wake
up, they're terrified,
they're confused,
they're scared,
they think they should
be home, and they're not.
They're in a strange hospital.
What they would end
up doing is constantly
leaving this hospital and
going down to the bus stop,
where they would be
waited on for hours.
What this study found out is
that the people in the hospital
would go down and start yelling
at these poor, elderly people
that were suffering
from the disease.
What you need to understand
is in that situation,
even if the patients-- if
the facts of the situation
were not that they were in a
place they weren't supposed
to be, their terror
was absolutely real.
Their frustration
So when these hospital employees
were coming down and yelling
at them, they didn't
realize that their emotions
in that situation
were very true.
What you need to do,
again, is start just
simply respecting those
lived experiences.
These are our lives.
These are our stories.
When you respect our
lived experience,
you end up respecting
us as individuals.
This really makes me frustrated.
There is a phenomena
when you talk
about women in tech issues.
I swear, it is like you're in
court, and all of a sudden,
you end up getting it
flipped, and you end up
talking about how these
issues affect men.
It is amazing to me just how
instantly the script flips,
and I find the
subject-- if I'm talking
about the things I face,
the subject instantly
comes to if it's fair to men.
Let me give you an example.
Yesterday, Apple had
a rather large event.
They were talking about the
iPad Pro, the new Apple TV,
and I was live tweeting
a few thoughts about it.
I couldn't help but note for
the first 30 minutes of it,
there were barely
any women on stage.
So I tweet something to
the effect of, well, here
are all Apple's white guys, here
are all Microsoft's white guys,
and now we've got Adobe's
white guys coming on stage.
I'm deluged with tweets
from people saying,
well, you can't have quotas
for women you can't do this,
how dare you insinuates
that men shouldn't
be on stage, which is a
really, really, really,
unhelpful response.
I want to talk a little bit
about where that comes from.
You may have heard the word
privilege a little bit lately.
And the truth is,
men in this field
are kind of blind to
how great you've got it.
I don't think you
understand what
it's like to go to
an engineering event
and be the only person
that looks like you there.
I don't think you
understand what
it's like to go to
a recruiting event
and have people talk
to your husband,
assuming he's the engineer,
when he can't even update
the software on his iPhone.
This entire system has
been built for you,
for your comfort.
When we start talking about
other people's comfort,
you're so used to
it working for you
that just the slightest
bit of upset--
there's a lot of
defensiveness that
really happens very quickly
with that, and it's not helpful.
So again, this is not about
you, and I promise you,
every single woman
engineer in this room
has heard these opinions
100 times before,
like a tape on repeat.
With all respect, I
have heard the argument
against quotas for women in tech
hundreds of times this week.
There is a really,
really beautiful thing
called the ring theory that
I'd like to talk about.
The idea is how not to say
the wrong thing to someone.
So the idea is,
you are right here
in the center of the circle when
something goes wrong for you.
Imagine if you have cancer, or
you've just lost your spouse,
or you're going
through a divorce,
or your parents have died, or
you've got 165 death threats
in a year.
Imagine you were here in
the center of the circle.
This is not a good place to be.
So what the
psychologist figured out
is, when you were in the center
of the circle-- she had cancer.
She had a colleague
come to her while she
was in the hospital recovering
from cancer surgery who
said to her, well, you need
to realize this cancer isn't
all about you, it's affecting
people in our department.
And she thought a lot
about that conversation
and why that was so obnoxious.
So there's this thing
called the ring theory.
At the center of the
circle-- which again, is not
a good place to be--
is the aggrieved.
In the outer limits of
the circle might be close
family members, loved
ones, your spouse.
On the outer circle might be
colleagues, and on the thing
here might be strangers.
The idea is, comfort flows
in, grievance flows out.
If you're not in the
center of the circle,
or in one of these inner rings,
inevitably making it about you
is unfortunately obnoxious.
What you need to
do is very simple.
Just listen instead.
OK.
This is a really big one.
I want to talk very openly
and honestly about this.
I'm a 38-year-old engineer.
I don't have any
children, and my husband
and I made the choice to really
hyper focus on our careers.
I had been blind to
this for a long time,
and I was very blind
to this until I
had women with children
come work for me,
or people on my
staff get pregnant.
In the game industry,
where I work,
we talk a lot about
things like death threats,
rape threats, sexual
harassment, women
getting hit on at conventions.
Something we're
almost silent about
is the way we treat women
with children in tech.
And this doesn't
personally affect me,
but I want to tell you
straight up, in my career,
I've seen more women leave over
this issue than anything else.
Someone in a society has
to have the children.
It's not like women made a
choice about this, right?
And what I think
people don't understand
is how ridiculously
expensive child care is.
Here in Massachusetts,
do you know
that having day
care for your child
is as expensive as
tuition at UMass?
I want you really
to think about that.
Every single year your
child is in day care,
that costs tuition and fees.
Absolutely.
It's unconscionable.
This is a really big deal.
So what ends up happening when
women have children in tech
is they end up slowly,
suddenly, being shown the door.
Again, I have
unconscious biases, too,
and what I found at first when
my employee with a child--
she got pregnant, my
co-founder, and I found myself
wrestling with all these
unconscious biases.
Is Amanda going to be
present at our workplace?
Is she going to be able
to get her job done?
Is she going to start talking
about her kids non-stop, which
was absolutely wrong
for me to think.
I've thought about that
and I've grown from that.
This is the unconscious
bias a lot of people have.
What you need to know-- and this
is for parents of all genders,
not just women--
part of respecting
a parent in the workforce means
respecting their children.
That means if a
parent needs to leave
at five to go pick
their child up,
respecting that person
means respecting
that their family comes first.
This is really,
really important.
This is a really hard one,
and I've run into this a lot
in Boston.
I can't tell you how
many networking events
I've been to in a bar, at
night, with a bunch of dudes
in their 20s, drinking.
Right here in Boston there was
one of them we went to a while
back that was right
across the street.
What has happened in the
field of computer science
and engineering is,
this is a field that
was built from the ground
up to be by men for men.
I want to stress, this
is unconscious bias.
But what ends up
happening is you
have a culture of
networking that
is built to serve men
in the way that you
like to network, like going
to a bar and having beer.
Let's take that
example, for a minute,
because I'd for you
to think about it.
Let's say you were an engineer
at Google in your 20s,
and you choose to go
have a meeting out
with the guys on
your team at the bar
next door after you leave.
Let's think about how
that's affecting women.
If you're a woman in, say, your
20s, I think you may not know,
that doesn't feel
emotionally very frequently
like a safe place for you-- a
lot of guys drinking heavily
and you're the lone woman there.
I can think of three specific
friends that have been sexually
harassed in that
situation to the point
that they've been forced
to leave their company,
and HR hasn't helped them.
It's not the best situation.
If you are a woman in
your 30s, maybe you
have children, how
many moms do you
know that really want to
go hit a bar at 8 o'clock
at night when their kids have
to go to school the next day?
This is one of these situations
where the system has been built
to work for a very
certain kind of person,
and it very unintentionally
excludes a lot of people.
And let's be honest-- networking
is how you make careers.
It makes or breaks it.
This is really important.
So what we need people to
do, what I need everyone
in this room to do, is to think
about widening your network.
If Google has a networking
meeting or recruitment
meeting to bring
in engineers, maybe
don't have them
in a bar at night.
Maybe have a luncheon
here at one o'clock
like we're having right now.
Maybe do it earlier.
It's not enough to
just simply believe
that women need to be included.
I'm a software engineer.
If I go write some code for
my game and it doesn't run,
the problem is with my code.
I don't sit there
and go, well, I just
don't know why it's not working.
We'll just keep compiling
it and that will be that.
The method that we use to
recruit engineers in our field
is not working.
I've heard from so
many people when
they tell me, well, we
put a job posting online,
and no women applied, and
that's just the end of that.
We have made so
many advancements
in the last 15, 20
years, and yet we
can't look at the hiring
process and realize it
overlooks a lot of candidates.
Let me tell you a story.
It's a story of how the
lead engineer at my team
came to work at my company.
This is a woman that was
fresh out of college.
She had not gone on the
straight and narrow.
She didn't get a CS degree
and then just instantly
get into the workforce.
She had some life
adventures along the way.
She had been working
for us part time,
and we were just
dazzled by her work.
She was doing technical
rigging in 3-D, which is
very, very difficult process.
We loved her work and
we kept encouraging
her to apply to the
lead engineer position,
and she didn't do it.
I asked her to keep
coming in and sit with me
as we were interviewing other
candidates for this position.
As we did that, she
realized that she
had the exact same
qualifications as the men
we were interviewing
for that position,
and that gave her the
confidence to move forward.
Just for whatever
reason-- and it's really
too much to get into
here-- a lot of women
are kind of trained by society
to not believe in ourselves,
and we don't always apply
for these kinds of positions.
So what you need to do is to
widen your networking efforts
to make sure you're looking
at absolutely everyone.
We face a lot more inertia to
getting our foot in the door.
OK.
This is hard.
So many times, when you try
to talk to people in tech
about even a very small
behavioural thing they might
have done that is not helpful,
it gets defensive very, very,
very quickly.
And I think part of this problem
is self identifying yourself
as a racist or a
sexist or a homophobe
is nearly impossible,
because we get
all these messages from society
that these things are bad.
They're terrible.
What ends up happening is
you tell yourself, hey,
I'm not a bad person.
I'm a nice guy.
I care about women.
You think of this
extreme example,
and you say, I'm not that,
and you self identify yourself
as a nice person, and
you're unable to hear
any of the criticism there.
And I want to be
straight up with you.
I think we could do a
better job with this
as a society of
giving people a break.
I think we have a really
unfortunate tendency to,
when someone makes one mistake,
often unconscious, often
unintentional, kind of
crucifying them about it,
to be honest.
I make mistakes all
the time in my field.
I've told you about some today.
I don't think that
makes me a bad person.
We have got to get
past this so we
can hear about these behavior
problems and move forward.
I think it's really telling
in all the years I've
been speaking about
women in tech issues,
I have almost never had a
guy come up to me afterwards
and say, hey Brianna, you know
what, I am part of the problem.
There has almost never happened.
It's always those other guys.
It's always the other examples.
The truth is, if you think that
the problem is someone else,
you are part of the problem.
We've talked a lot this
year about people of color,
and again, to give
an example where
I have failed-- we had my
staff for the last game
that we shipped,
"Revolution 60," happened
to be all white people.
I looked at that and I
realized that I was not
bringing people of color
into my own company,
to evaluate people of
color for these positions.
I realized I had
a responsibility
to change myself, change
when network happens
and make sure it was
bringing people of color
in for those positions.
This is a mindset where I'm not
saying, hey, I'm not a racist,
hey, I have nothing to fix
here, hey, I have no part
to play in making it better.
This is a very helpful attitude
that all of us need to have.
Again, this is all about
responsibility and thinking
critically about your behavior.
What I love about
one of the videos
I've seen from Google,
An Unconscious Bias,
is what they found
is the science shows
if you take one of the things
I'm talking about today,
if you just take one
thing, if you say hey,
I'm not networking
enough with women, hey,
I am invalidating people's
experiences-- if you make
a commitment to just change one
thing today-- the science shows
that that is going to cause you
to start thinking about more
things, and it will make you a
better person and a better team
mate.
We all make mistakes.
There is a misconception,
I feel, in tech,
that the problem women face
is like Don Draper sitting
in a tech office somewhere,
drinking some scotch,
and talking about how
broads can't code.
Like that's the
hypothetical situation
that we think discrimination
is in this field.
I have never had,
from a professional,
someone tell me to go
back to the kitchen.
These kind of moments
are not the real problem.
What we've set up is
this idea in our minds
that the real problem is
some raging sexist stereotype
from the 50s.
The science shows
that's not quite right.
Sexism in tech, according
to the science of it,
is death by 1,000 cuts.
And what happens is that
it's every single day you're
in this field, if you're someone
that's a person of color,
or someone that's gay,
someone that's a woman,
you find yourself slowly
dying the death of 1,000 cuts.
And how that happens is it's
little things all day long.
People not inviting
you to meetings,
people underestimating your
capacity as an engineer, people
assuming that you
don't know your field,
even when you may have dedicated
your entire career for it.
I had an example yesterday.
I was talking at
the Apple TV event.
I will tell you,
straight up, I know more
about running the Unreal Engine
on Apple platforms, Apple
mobile platforms, than
almost anyone else.
You can probably
find, 20, 30 people,
maybe, in the world
that understand
the subject as much as I do.
I was talking critically
about some of the engineering
choices that Apple
made when developing
this platform, in
particular the 200 megabyte
limit, which is kind of
obviated by a cloud solution.
I was inundated by hundreds
and hundreds of people
writing me, assuming they knew
more than I did in this field,
and telling me I was
wrong, when all they had
was a rather obvious fact that
was mentioned in some tech
documents.
This is a really good example
of a death of 1,000 cuts.
This is just one minor
thing that happens,
but it happens over and over
and over and over and over.
They're called
micro aggressions,
and they kind of slowly
push you out of the field.
Another good example.
At Apple's event
yesterday, they happened
to Photoshop a
picture of a woman
into smiling using
the new iPad pro.
This is a pretty tone
deaf moment, right?
Guys don't understand
how often, when
you're walking down the street,
you're instructed to smile.
You're told you
would be prettier
if you would just smile.
This happens all the time.
When Apple had not had any women
on stage yet at that point,
and they're Photoshopping
a woman in smiling,
it's a really tone deaf moment.
That's something a lot
of guys I saw on Twitter
just didn't understand.
It was just a little
thing that was really
just kind of obnoxious.
It pushes us away.
This is a really good example.
This happened last year.
This is just a slide at a
conference, and you know,
it's completely tone deaf.
Stuff like that will
happen to you almost every
single day if you're
a woman in this field.
What we need to
understand is real sexism
in this field is
very, very subtle.
A good example of this happened
here in Boston with Harmonix.
You might have read this week
that they got $15 million
in venture capital funding.
A friend of mine that
worked at Harmonix
was telling me this story.
She was setting out
in a meeting and they
were looking at getting
a new person to come in
for an engineering position.
The team leader kept
using masculine pronouns
when asking someone to
come in for the job.
Well, this engineer he should
have x years of experience
with x, y, and z.
He should be x.
He should live in x.
He should have this
kind of background.
She stopped him in the
meeting, and said, excuse me,
this could be a man or woman
that we hire for this position.
This engineer proceeded to
then completely talk over her,
belittle her objection, and
said, this is not a problem.
He means everybody.
That's just a very small
thing that happens.
It's subtle.
This is a really hard
thing to understand,
and this is something, again,
I have learned in my lifetime.
The absence of privilege
is not oppression.
And I say this with all respect
to all the male engineers
in this room, this is a
system that really, really
works for you.
When we're talking about
changing the system just
a little bit so other
people can come in
and you can have awesome
people on your team,
we are talking about
changing things.
And I want to be
clear, it is going
to disrupt some of the
boys' club atmosphere
that exists in tech.
That is not oppression.
That is a quality.
I want to give you
a very quick story.
So I was over at
MIT the other day,
and I was giving a presentation.
Afterwords, I had some people
that were really moved by it,
and they were telling me stories
about being out with drinks
with the guys afterwards.
There was this one engineer
that was on the team
and he was sitting there.
He was having drinks
out with his buddies,
and he was really, really angry
about the talk that I gave.
He was talking about how
he felt like he had never
fit in anywhere in his
whole life-- something
I have a lot of empathy for.
I can understand
that, because I felt
the entire same way growing up.
What he was saying was he
was really, really scared.
The attack was going
to change to this place
where he couldn't have
bro time, couldn't
have pictures of bikini
girls on his screen saver,
and it would be a different
kind of atmosphere.
As much as my heart
goes out to that person,
because I think
we all have a need
to want to belong
to a social group,
it's not fair for him to
prioritize his own comfort
over just equality
for gay people,
for women, for people of color.
The culture tech has been
built in your own image.
I was at PAX Dev two weeks
ago, and I found myself-- there
was this weird moment.
It was a 23-year-old kid.
He's a white guy, and he's
sitting there talking to me,
and he was talking
about how he was
terrified that he was never
going to find an engineering
position.
And the whole time I was
sitting there talking to him,
I was realizing all the
assumptions I had in my mind.
He looked like an engineer,
he had kind of messy hair,
and he was just
wearing a t-shirt
at a professional event.
He kind of looked
like that stereotype.
And in the back of my
mind, I'm going, of course
is going to find a job.
I found myself saying,
I don't know anything
about his technical expertise,
about his education,
I don't know anything
about how well he
plays with others.
But he looks like
the part, right?
It's just another example
of the entire tech industry
being built in your image.
When you close your eyes and
think about someone working
in this field, it
probably doesn't
look like me or other women.
And the truth is, I
get so much hate mail
in speaking out against this.
This is before Gamergate
that I got this.
This is just
absolutely terrible.
It's stuff like this I get
every single day speaking out
about this.
This is something that would
be of benefit to everyone
here to understand.
Let's be straight out.
Tech is going to change.
The momentum is on the
side of women and people
of color and other minorities.
We are talking about these
problems more and more and more
and I feel very confident
that tech in 10 years
is going to look different
than it does today.
I grew up in
Mississippi, which is
a state that was described
by MLK as sweltering
with the heat of
injustice and oppression.
Growing up, I sure
did meet a lot
of people that were extremely
homophobic or racist.
Even in my own social
groups, in college,
I would find these people.
What will inevitably happen,
especially with gay rights,
we'd kind of have
this person there
that was ranting
about gay people
being able to get married, and
they'd slowly be pushed out
of our social circle.
Do you know what I mean?
They just had views
that were kind of dated
and we started moving
away from them.
In the same way-- I'm
talking about this
in an utterly pragmatic terms--
this change is happening.
Your work force will include
more women in the future.
It's not just that this
is the right thing to do.
This is to your own
career advantage
to develop the skills to learn
to work with other people.
One of the best skills
for any tech professional
is being able to work
well with a team.
A lot of times, when I talk
about women in tech issues,
there's this assumption
that women in tech
is just a chick thing, right?
Oh, well, you know, that's
just a women problem,
and I don't really
have to deal with that.
I was at a tech
event last night.
It was a VIP event with
investors and women startup
founders.
As much as I love
events like that,
it sometimes feels like there's
a trade off in this field
where the powers that
be will let women
go have our lunches
over here, and they'll
pay for us to have an auditorium
and do some networking events.
But nothing really changes.
I'm going to tell you, in
all honesty, straight up,
sexism in tech is not a
problem with women's behavior.
I'm going to say
that one more time.
Sexism in tech is not a
problem with women's behavior.
This is a male behavior problem.
I can be up here and I can speak
to you about changing this,
but the only person that
can make this better is you.
What we're going to do
is we're going to start
a conversation right now.
I'll answer any question
in the entire world.
Who's going to be brave enough
to put their hand up first?
And we will do that.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hi.
Thanks for having the courage
to come here and give this talk.
BRIANNA WU: I appreciate that.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Your slides
are refreshingly direct.
I didn't expect him to
be that so, because I
found that people don't seem
to respond to them that well.
But in your experience, if
you're with a bunch of people,
one of them makes a comment
that they don't understand
is inappropriate.
Have you found it's
better to actually
be more direct with
them and just say,
straight up, that's
wrong, instead of saying,
well, maybe it's
not quite like that?
BRIANNA WU: That's a
wonderful question.
Let me answer it
equally directly.
If you're a woman and you do
that, that direct conversation,
you will get
tremendous blowback,
which is why so many of the
women I know in game dev
are very, very careful about
dancing around this issue,
and just hinting to it
as subtly as she can,
because she gets
so much blowback.
This is where you
personally can do the most
good in the entire world.
With the Gamergate thing,
we do have men on our field
that are speaking now.
Chris Kluwe is one of them.
Arthur Chu would be another.
They don't get a fraction of
the death threats that I get,
or Anita gets, or Zoe Quinn
gets, or Randi Harper gets.
What happens is when you
have that male privilege,
you are able to kind of pull
your buddy aside and be like,
hey, can we just
talk about that?
That's not really cool
what you just said.
Just have an open conversation
with them about that.
That's almost no risk for you.
I think if you're
a woman, you need
to realize there are going
to be blowback for that.
I personally made the choice
to just answer it directly.
I'm not Oprah Winfrey,
again, but this
is where I would really ask
guys to step up and help us out.
You can do so much
good, you have no idea.
Let's go to another question
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I suspect
most people here in the room
are probably on your
side, are probably
very receptive to this message.
BRIANNA WU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Yeah,
I am too, and thank you
for coming to give the talk.
Do you think it's
better to try to engage
people who aren't here and
maybe wouldn't be as receptive?
Or do you think
it's better for them
to come to this conversation
of their own volition?
BRIANNA WU: Sure.
I think that's a
really good question.
Did anyone else
here see the piece
on Vox last week
that was talking
what nerds don't understand
about politics by Dr.
[INAUDIBLE]?
Did you see that?
That was a 10 out of 10 talk.
I called up that writer
on the phone afterwards,
and I started asking him
that exact question, how
we could get that answer.
Let me tell you about
the science of it.
I know Google
nerds love science.
He has a lot of expertise in
climate change denial, people
that don't want to
believe in global warming.
What happens is, with some
people, you are correct,
it is impossible to
change their minds.
There's nothing that
you can say that is ever
going to make them feel
differently on that.
You cannot scientifically
change someone's opinion.
What you can change
scientifically
is someone's behavior.
The human mind has this
really interesting trait
that we'd like to
think of ourselves
as rational creatures,
but we're not.
We have this
psychological trick where
we decide how we want
to feel, and then
our minds act like lawyers
and justify the thing
that we want to believe.
If you're a programmer, you've
learned to short circuit
that to a certain extent.
We tend to be very
logical creatures,
but that is the
overall human tendency.
You can't change
someone's opinion.
You can change their behavior.
So what happens if
you make a social cost
to that person doing something,
if every single time they
speak up, they face
consequences for that?
Even if it's just some
guy going, hey, that's
not really cool, hey, that made
me feel uncomfortable, hey,
can you think about
this way, maybe?
What happens over time is you
change that behavior, and then
the psychological trick where
you decide how you want to feel
and then the mind
justifies it, you
decide that you want to
feel like not doing this,
because the social cost is less.
And then your attitudes
slowly start to change.
With the climate
change denial thing,
this would be if you
can get through any way
possible-- to get tax
rebates, to get people
to put solar panels
on their roof
to save on energy efficiency.
What they found when you do
that is their opinions change.
You can have the most dedicated
climate change denier,
but once they get
that government tax
rebate to put solar
panels on their roof,
suddenly, they're a proponent
of renewable energy.
It's exactly the same
way in the field.
So scientifically, that is
the best weapon that we have.
Do we have another question?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: First
of all, thank you
for the choice you're making.
I cannot imagine choosing to
live a life where death threats
were just sort of a
background fact of it.
BRIANNA WU: It's really bad.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I think it's
necessary to have conversations
in this space, for there
to be people like you,
so I'm grateful for you
for doing something I
don't think I'd be able to do.
The question I was
curious about asking
is, do you have some
understanding or intuition
about where the depth
of vitriol comes from?
BRIANNA WU: Sure.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:
Some of it, I buy,
is being the confusion
between absence of privilege
and oppression, and
I get that, but it
doesn't feel like enough to me,
and there's something about it
that I'm just not
wrapping my brain.
BRIANNA WU: Oh, I spent
an entire year thinking
about this question.
This is very insightful.
This is as best as
I can figure it,
because that's getting at the
core of the problem, which
I love.
How many people here are gamers?
Can you raise your
hand if you're a gamer?
Great.
The biggest mistake
my parents ever made
was getting Nintendo
entertainment system in 1985.
I remember opening
that box at Christmas,
and I remember my grades went
to hell, I stopped socializing,
I stopped doing my
chores, and that
was all I did-- I still do it.
What I remember about that
era-- and this was 30 years ago,
like Mario turns 30 soon,
guys, this is really amazing--
what I remember
about this era was
how marketed the
product was for boys.
And this shows up in
all these subtle ways.
Do you know there have
only been two core Mario
games where you could play as a
girl character, Princess Peach?
The first was "Super
Mario 2" in 1988,
and then as far as
the core Mario titles,
we had to wait 25 years
for Princess Peach
to be playable again.
Making this a boy space was
very deliberately chosen
by the Nintendo marketing
team back in 1985.
They said that
they were targeting
boys between 5 and 10.
Then when the Super
Nintendo came out in 1982,
they just rewrote the
same document and said,
we're targeting
boys 5 to 15 now.
What has happened
is, I think we'd
like to say that the
problem is a bunch
of misogynistic
15-year-olds, and that
is part of the problem.
But I think if you want
to look at it more deeply,
there are all these
unconscious messages.
They've been telling
boys, now 35-year-old men,
that games are their space.
It's not women's space.
It happens in all
these subtle ways.
Princess Peach is always waiting
to be rescued in the castle.
When women are in games, we
are frequently over sexualized.
We're always the sidekick
or the damsel in distress,
and we have huge, giant boobs
with lots of cleavage out.
And what it is, is 1,000
unconscious signals that
have been sent to men
saying, this is for you,
this is not for women.
They have this
intellectual shortcut
where they might be
theoretically fine with women
playing games, but the instant
we bring their lived experience
into it and say, well, it
really hurts me to never
be able to be the playable
character in a game,
well, I'd like to see a
woman larger than size six
represented in a video game.
How many games can you
think of where you've seen
a mom as a playable character?
Do know what percentage
of women are going
to have kids in their lifetime?
It's all unconscious by
the people in our field,
but they feel-- it's kind
of the same as politics.
Certain people feel their
identity is being taken away,
and they get very defensive.
Did you have a follow up?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I do.
BRIANNA WU: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: If I
take what you're saying,
and I take it to sort of try
and wrap my brain around it,
what I'm hearing is that
people create or adopt
or dive into spaces that are
restricted to one set of people
when they are threatened
by another set of people.
So I'm hearing you as saying
that people who are feeling--
and you can look at
what they say online,
and it's pretty clear, too.
BRIANNA WU: Look through my
Twitter mentions sometime.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:
Saying that there
is a class of men
that feel threatened
by the presence of women in
gaming seems a little obvious,
but it does bring up
the next question, which
is sort of, why?
What's going on there that
those people feel like they
need that space to feel safe?
BRIANNA WU: Let me only tell
you another a quick story.
I grew up in Mississippi,
so my senator
at the time, Trent
Lott-- I actually
worked for him one summer.
We'll leave that there.
Don't judge me.
I was very young.
My senator, Trent Lott, once
did a study for the Republican
Party in the south-- and I'm
keeping this very apolitical,
we're just talking
about facts here--
he did a study
looking at what would
drive voter behavior to vote
for the Republicans that year.
They tested all these questions
like, the Democrats will
raise taxes, blah, blah, blah.
They found this one question
that raised through the roof
the response of it.
The question was, the Democrats
want to take away your culture.
And white Southern males
just responded off the charts
to this, just ridiculously high.
What happens is, there's
a really deep set
evolutionary part
of our brain where
we're programmed from back when
we were living in caves to have
in groups and out groups, and
we're just programmed to say,
we're in this group, and
then this group over here
is the other, and
they are a threat.
You can see that portrayed all
through history, through war,
through all of this stuff.
What's happening is
it's really tapping
into a very reptilian,
primordial part of the brain
where people feel like,
this is their in group.
Their identity is based
in it, and they're scared
it's going to be taken away.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I
just wanted to pass
on a question from a speaker
last month, [INAUDIBLE]
who just wanted to know what
we might see next from you,
and also, how friends
can help with anything
you're working on.
BRIANNA WU: Oh, that's
a really great question.
I love her.
You should check out her book.
What I am working on next is--
as if dealing with Gamergate
were not big enough for me,
we are working on the venture
capital scene right now to do a
multi-million dollar expansion.
I can't talk about
some of it, but we're
very interested in what we're
calling emotional game play
dynamic.
To me, I feel like we
have reinvented this wheel
for 30 years in the
video game industry.
How many first person
shooters have you played?
Because let's be
honest, Call of Duty
is not that different than Doom.
It's like we keep reinventing
the same idea because it's
the same people there.
What we're doing is
taking a step back
from the entire
video game industry,
from all the assumptions that
we've made, and we're saying,
what is the goal in the
video game industry?
To me, the goal is a holodeck.
The goal is a holodeck
and to go and interact
with different kinds of
people in emotional ways
and learn things about
yourself along the way.
As we really have an
explosion in VR technology,
we have some very interesting
ideas about frameworks
to develop from this.
We're raising millions
of dollars for that.
As far as how to help
me-- guys, if I personally
dealt with all of my
death threats myself,
I would not do anything
else with my time.
There's just too much of it.
And it's sad, but I'm just
being straight with you,
being up here today, people
will see this video on Google,
I will get threats,
I will get attacked.
I have to employ in my
company a full time person
to deal with my harassment,
to talk to prosecutors,
to talk to the FBI, to
document this stuff,
because I could not work
in this field if I did.
I have a Patreon where people
can help pay for that position,
because startups don't have
room for extra positions
to pay people to
file death threat
charges with prosecutors.
That's how you can help.
Maybe we'll give a link
to that in the video.
Thanks for that question.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Stepping
back to the attitudes
that lead to the horribleness--
it makes me wonder,
were the cultural
watchdogs right all along,
that these games were corrupting
us during our formative years
with destructive attitudes?
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
BRIANNA WU: Can I tell you
the weirdest story about that?
Who else here was a gamer in
the 90s with Jack Thompson?
Do you remember that, when
they were worried about "Mortal
Kombat" corrupting the youth?
I remember being a
teenager and being
like, oh, that's so
stupid, that's so dumb,
that's so full of crap.
I'm not saying that it's
not, but I will tell you
an experience that I had.
They're coming
out with "Hatred,"
which is this game that's
a mass murder simulator.
You have a certain
person on Steam
that is demanding the creators
add modifiable tools so people
can put me in that game
to kill, and Zoe Quinn,
and Anita Sarkeesian.
I have gamers that
want to do that.
I keep thinking back
to being a teenager
and my strong opinion about
violence doesn't matter.
I'm just be a straight up, I
don't have an answer there.
I think we should be able to
make whatever games that we
want.
I'm certainly not
pro censorship,
but I think something's
really wrong in our industry.
I think we need to
think about that.
Does that answer your question?
I'm not going to tell you we
need to start censoring games.
I don't.
I think it's impossible in an
age of digital distribution.
But what I do believe
is that Nintendo,
Sony, Microsoft, and Steam
have a responsibility
to think about the product
that they're putting out.
When Steam reversed
their decision
and did decide to
release "Hatred" which
is made by neo Nazis--
it's a white power thing
to just go kill people.
You watch the
trailer and there's
a woman begging on her
knees for her life,
and you'll stick a shotgun
in her mouth and kill her.
It is horrific.
I don't think you should
censor that by the government,
and I think in an age of
digital distribution anyone
can play the game if they want.
I think we should do that.
Can we do two question
super quickly?
Great.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: You mentioned
a couple of micro aggression.
You mentioned mansplaining
and interrupting.
I wonder if there's
any others you
want to call out as
maybe anything that's
specific to the software
development environment?
BRIANNA WU: I think
that a really big one
would be assuming women
do not know their stuff.
That's a really, really big one.
It hurts a lot.
I think talking over women in
meetings, and let me say this,
I love gender neutral examples.
Look, a lot of us here
are software engineers.
Almost all the engineers
I know are introverts.
I'm not, but the
vast majority are.
What I have noticed in
running my company is
if I don't take a firm
hand, the extroverts end
up talking over
everyone and introverts
can't get a word in edgewise.
This includes a lot of women.
If you are product manager, you
have a strong responsibility
as a team leader to shut
down the extroverts like me
for monopolising the
entire conversation
and letting everyone be heard.
I could go into a
whole bunch of them,
but I think that's
a good example.
Last question.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:
I was wondering--
there was a time in the late
tube and early transistor days
when computer operators
were mostly women,
and because [INAUDIBLE]
switchboard operation,
it was basically
seen as secretarial.
My question was, are
there any lessons
we can draw from the
path of computing?
Is there a time when it
was indeed mostly women?
It wasn't a
prestigious position.
It became a prestigious
position, then came men.
Is there anything we can
learn from the early part
of that history?
BRIANNA WU: Yes, that's
a historical pattern.
Believe it or not,
there's a huge pattern
through history of field
coming along and being born.
It starts off as
very prestigious,
and women are drawn to it, and
there's a pattern over and over
again that men move into the
field and end up changing it.
I would love to tell
you what happened
in computing in those early
days is like an aberration,
but it's not.
There is so much
baggage that women
face to working as
professional engineers.
I see this was someone
my friends' children,
who are 14, 15 right now.
And they're put into a culture
where beauty culture starts
telling them who their friends,
are what they look like,
is so much more important than
doing that work we all know
is so important,
sitting in your bedroom
and learning how to code.
There are 1,000 messages
like that we really
have to move past as a society.
I've got to leave
it there today.
Thank you all for having me.
I appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]